Je vais vous dire que l'objectif ultime des
Russes et personnellement du président
Poutine est de laisser les sanctions le plus
rapidement possible et il essaiera de jouer des
tours pour trouver des alliés dans le
monde occidental afin d'obtenir une sorte de compromis
afin de partir  les sanctions et de
rejoindre le club des pays normaux nos
relations avec le Canada sont très
fortes pour un certain nombre de raisons eh bien la
régulière la raison normale ou ordinaire est
que nous avons je dirais même des
relations familiales avec le Canada en raison d'une énorme
diaspora canado-ukrainienne  mais le Canada
était et je crois qu'il sera très fort pour
soutenir l'Ukraine, nous pensons que le
peuple canadien se tient aux côtés du peuple ukrainien dans la
lutte contre l'agression russe,
il ne s'agit pas seulement de l'Ukraine, monsieur, il s'agit
des valeurs du monde libre. La
Russie est un agresseur, ils  annexé illégalement la
Crimée ils ont envahi Donetsk et
Lougansk ils ont commis un
crime international et se précipitent pour en payer le prix mais
pas pour trouver le moyen de contourner ce
genre de re  responsabilité, il est important
non seulement de parler, mais de livrer et je
crois que le nouveau gouvernement canadien
sera blond, fort et ferme en faisant
pression sur la Russie, ce qui est d'une
importance cruciale pour nous, monsieur, car nous avons en
fait restauré l'armée ukrainienne au
cours des 24 derniers mois, nous ne l'avons pas fait
l'armée ukrainienne a été
démantelée délibérément démantelée par l'
ancien régime avec le soutien de
la phase B russe et d'agents russes, nous sommes donc
partis de zéro et pour aujourd'hui, le
défendeur ukrainien n'est pas seulement l'
ukraine, nous défendons les frontières de
l'union européenne ah donc la
priorité clé  pour nous tous est de rendre
l'armée ukrainienne
suffisamment solide et de fournir toutes
les capacités possibles et impossibles à l'
armée ukrainienne pour lutter contre l'
agression dirigée par la Russie.
pour répondre à toutes les
normes de l'OTAN parce que notre objectif ultime est
de rejoindre l'OTAN mr.  Poutine a dit qu'ils
n'accepteraient jamais que vous rejoigniez la marine franchement,
je me fiche de ce que Poutine a dit, je me soucie de ce que les
Ukrainiens le croient, ils
veulent faire partie du monde libre du
monde occidental, ils veulent être
membres de l'union européenne et  ils
veulent rejoindre l'otan parce que c'est la
seule alliance qui peut défendre notre
pays mon pays se bat contre
l'agression dirigée par la russie c'est le
vrai pays démocratique et ces gens
à ma fin ils se sont battus pour la
liberté d'expression gratuitement  et des
élections équitables et pour les vraies valeurs européennes,
nous avons été envahis par les Russes et je
peux difficilement imaginer qui a le courage même de
dire ou même de penser ou une idée de laisser les
sanctions jusqu'à ce que la Russie mette pleinement en œuvre
l'accord de moyens